[Musique]
oh non c'est sûr hier et ont dit qu'il
n'y ait pas pas vous ne pouvez plus
j'en ai marre tu mérites je suis seul
à
marie quoi
vous êtes perdus je peut vous conduire
si vous voulez
[Musique]
bonjour l'ambiance
zabita aurait tonné et toutes les nuits
le fils il est sur sa barque cherche
sûrement son père qui s'est noyé
sa dette le fils à jeanne martin un
grand gars à vous rappeler que vous êtes
pas du tout
[Musique]
je dérange vous cherchez quelque chose
vous n'avez pas vu mon fils
les autres ordinaire
à respecter mon stand j'ai eu mon dieu
tu vas je ne veux pas être avec vous
tout le temps comprenez ça
martin bébé c'était un ange et puis très
vite il est devenu cruel il s'est mis à
me torturer
martin ce qu'on connaît pas
je
personne n'a suivi pas les dingues
[Musique]
oh